Good morning, my name is Diane Campione and I am here with Rita Cedar.
at Lifestyles Recording for Visible Lives. Good morning, Rita! Good morning.
Tell me a little bit about yourself: Where are you from? Um, originally?
Yes. I'm from Long Island, and uhh, now I live on Staten Island.
Okay, and I want you to tell me: What makes you different from other
individuals?
Well, I have the walker, but I don't feel that I'm different.
Do you um mind if I ask you what your disability is?
I can't walk well, I need a walker for support. And, umm...
you live at home? Do you live at home? I live in an apartment house.
Is there a service personnel or a device besides the walker that you use to make it more
adaptable or more accessible for yourself? I use a cane
or the walker, preferably the walker. And that makes navigating things
easier for you? Much easier. OK. I want you to tell me a little bit
about who you are. What type of person do you think you are?
Kind, generous, uh aggressive...
um, strong? I think I'm a strong person.
And would you say that is... would you consider your life difficult?
Because of the walker, it
it is difficult, but I I
know I do things that I'm capable of doing. What makes things
difficult for you? What type of things? Shopping. I have, I can put things.
In a bag on my walker, on the side of it. Going places,
working stairs is very different.
Do you find that most um industry or most
when you go shopping, are they, is there accessibility for you within those places? Do you feel that's
something that's lacking? When I'm shopping? No, I don't. I sit
on the walker, right on line. Okay, and can you tell me who
has been the most important person in your life? Could be
somebody from way long ago or current.
I think going to Manor Road is the most important thing.
I've made friends here. And when I was in the hospital,
my friends visited me all the time. I have no family here. I live alone.
[background noise]
When you see Manor Road, you mean the JCC? The JCC, yes. Oh, that's wonderful, so is it a social group?
It's a social group and we go out together, we have lunch together every
day. And
And what do—Right here. Right here, at this Manor Road. And what would you say is the
the, one of the most important things about having social groups?
Can you give me a specific about what you think is, what you think is more beneficial about having these
groups?
I know that if I fell, somebody would be there. If I needed help,
they would help me. They did in the past. That's wonderful.
I have a, umm, famous quote that I've been asking people: the
only person you are destined to become is the person you decide to be. What kind of a
person do you think you've decided to be? The one that can take care of
myself. A friendly person, and a giving person. That's wonderful.
Can you finish the sentence for me: I draw my strength from
God. And I'd like to ask you finally: what
would you like to tell people? What would you like people to
know about individuals such as yourself, that use um a
wheelchair or a walker or a cane to navigate their
surroundings. What message would you like them to know? Just do it and get out. There are means,
People will help you. I know now people open the door and I say oh I'm just
using this because I want you to open the door. That's not true.
People are very kind, I've noticed. You found it? I think they're always fine but
I think they're kinder. That's good! That's very good. They're very polite.
[background noise]
The door's open. It's an extra early of an obstacle I'm curious
to know if there is anything that you would like changed in
society. For um how we as individuals should
be helping people like you. Is
Is there anything else? Realize that they could be next in line. It could happen to them, just like
it happened to me. That's very interesting. So say for today I'm gonna
be able to work. And then all of a sudden I couldn't.
Well. Thank you so much for sharing your story really well just lovely nice meeting you.